good morning everybody thanks for coming
to the third lecture on computational
cancer biology so the topic then for
this morning is cancer progression
models we talked a lot about the
evolution of cancer yesterday already
and just to remind you in very simple
terms there's typically a clonal origin
of the cancers a single cell the first
change occurs in a single cell and in
the in the course of evolution
additional mutations are accumulating
and these cells continue to change the
phenotypes increase their capacity to
grow and to out-compete other cells and
eventually some of these cells might be
able to leave the tissue of origin then
we speak of an invasive carcinoma or
even seed new tumors in other organs and
creating the cactuses so now we're
interested in this process that I call
you a genetic progression and mainly
we're interested in the way how
mutations accumulate in the tumor and
what are the dependencies among those
mutations so again the simple model that
probably applies to many even if not to
all tumors is is that of a simple series
of clonal expansions so the first
mutations mutation arising here again
gives rise to a clonal expansion meaning
that these cells have a growth advantage
and that they take over the tumor cell
population and at some point the second
mutation comes up the third one and so
on so in each individual tumor there's
such a series of clonal expansions now
the first model in a way for this
process not mathematical more about
conceptual model is is due to vogelstein
although the idea that multiple steps
are required in order for cancer to
progress are much older and in fact
already based on your cancer incidence
data and not on genomic data vogelstein
was one of the first to map out
pathway in some detail and he originally
did that for colorectal cancer so here's
the progression from normal tissue small
adenoma large adenoma so that's still
the benign tumor and then eventually the
carcinoma and maybe even metastases so
colorectal cancer he was able to map
mutations in specific genes to some of
these steps so for example the first one
here is mutations in a PC or beta
catenin and then there's a range of
other mutations kos p10 tp53 and so on
so this symbol here indicates the tumor
suppressor gene or mutation and tumor
suppressor gene and we talked yesterday
about how inactivation of tumor
suppressor gene works and this symbol
here stands for an oncogene so this
means the mutation that would activate
the oncogene so this linear progression
actually already in the original papers
by vogelstein he never claimed that in
each individual tumor it's exactly the
same linear progression and as we
discussed yesterday at length if we look
at the sequencing data that we observe
today it's it's simply not compatible
with a simple linear model that would
occur identically in every single tumor
so it's somehow more complex than that
but the basic idea is still that there
are some constraints on the order in
which these mutations occur and in a way
that's the main goal for this morning to
look at models that can that can infer
and estimate the order of genomic events
that occurred during tumor progression
so the simples simplest model then is a
is a linear progression model again just
a series of clonal expansions denoted
here by a b c and then d but it turns
out that if we look at different tumors
even of the same type histological time
this order of events is not the same in
each individual so we want the model to
take this into account and to connect
this a little further to what we talked
about yesterday so yesterday we talked
about phylogenetic methods and the basic
the data that we're using to do this is
a binary matrix where the samples are
indexing the rows here and the genetic
alterations the mutations or any other
aberration index the problem so it's
just a binary matrix and our main goal
yesterday was to estimate the
evolutionary relationship or the
dependencies among the samples so using
the profiles of mutations to describe
each sample and based on these data this
binary matrix our goal was to estimate
dependencies among samples in a way what
we're trying to do now and this is often
called a cancer progression models or
uncle genetic models is to do it in a
way that the transpose of that so now
the tumor samples are again here and the
genetic alterations are here but the
typical situation has indicated by the
different dimensions of these two
matrices is that we have a lot of
samples and that we're interested in the
dependencies among a rather small set of
alterations so there's a few key
mutations every would like to understand
what their dependency structure is so in
a way it's it's the same type of data we
are starting with also binary matrix and
and the rows and the columns are the
same meaning the rows to have a similar
or even the same meaning but we're now
interested in dependencies among genetic
alterations so this is what I will focus
on this morning ok so the outline is
then that I will start again with the
three model to describe these
dependencies that was the first model
doing this and it was termed an oncogene
etic tree this is why we call these Anka
genetic models and then we will
generalize a bit from trees to directed
acyclic graphs and then I will move on
to have a more explicit notion of the
dynamics of the waiting time how long
does it take for each such event to
occur and making inference in these
models then we will look more closely at
noisy observations as usual that
complicates inference very much and in
the last part I will talk a little bit
about
pathway level approaches or rather than
looking only at individual mutations or
individual genes trying to take into
account the fact that they operate in in
pathways and circuits and trying to
incorporate that into these models okay
so the basic notation and setup is very
simple by this vector X with components
X 1 up to xn I'm simply indicating the
occurrence of each of these n genetic
events so each X is a binary random
variable indicating whether certain
genetic event has occurred or not if it
has occurred it's equal to 1 and if not
it's equal to 0 so each observation of
this random vector is simply called
genotype because that's one realization
of all these possible mutations that
could occur and as I said we're
interested in the dependencies among the
mutations so in a way it's a very
general statistics problem by the high
dimensional data and we would like to
estimate dependencies covariance among
these random variables here but we will
make a few specific assumptions that
allow us to interpret these models as
progression models because we clearly
want a notion of order and the notion of
of direction in our models so we will
assume throughout that the mutations are
non-reversible so once you know the bit
has slipped from 0 to 1 it cannot flip
back and we were more or less throughout
require that all predecessor events in a
tree for example in the model of one
mutation need to occur before the
mutation itself can occur and I will
make that more precise in each of the
models we're looking at so also
connecting to the population dynamics
view we had yesterday at the very end
and the way we think of this is that
there's a population of cells and each
line is supposed to be the genome of one
such cell that initially might have no
mutation an augmentation means there can
be some low frequency mutation but none
of these is fixed and here the insights
we are looking at
after a certain period of time in tumor
progression that might be mutations that
have reached fixation in the population
and again this will be the result of a
clonal expansion so in a way the model
today is is much simpler much more
coarse grained in the sense that we're
just recording that mutation has reached
fixation and is now present in the tumor
cell population and that means that it
can be detected by by sequencing it's
not low frequency anymore so it's not a
big deal to detect these clonal
mutations here okay so let me start with
the trees because they are simplest and
also because historically they have been
around first so in a way I would argue
they start at the field so an oncogenic
tree is a very simple mod let's just
look at the graph here on the right here
on my random variables X 1 up to xn
which is x 4 here and I added an X 0
which is just the root node and which we
just set equal to one so you can read
this as a Bayesian network so the the
edges in this graph just denote
statistical dependencies and whenever
there's not an edge it means that these
two nodes are conditionally independent
so as a major network the oncogene etic
tree is defined by a factorization over
these local probability distributions
and you have one such local probability
distribution for each vertex and in that
local probability distribution you have
to say what is the probability of this
mutation occurring given the state of
the ancestor of the parent in the tree
right and that probability matrix for
binary random variables usually has two
free parameters right and what we're
doing in these oncogenic three models is
we are specializing this matrix so the
first row of this matrix doesn't have
any free parameters anymore and what it
says is that that the the particular
node can acquire the mutation with only
with probability zero credit cannot
acquire the mutation
if the predecessor mutation was not
present so the first row in this matrix
ensures that a mutation can only occur
if the parent mutation has already
occurred if it has not occurred it will
not happen and then there's only one
free parameter here per local
probability distribution and that's just
the probability to for that mutation to
happen given that the predecessor
mutation has already occurred so in a
way it's just a Beijing tree model with
a with a specialized with a more
specific local probability distribution
so let's look at an example here's my
root vertex again and since there's only
one free parameter I just from no one
called theta1 theta2 theta3 so just name
it by the vertex the edge is pointing to
so let's now compute for example the
probability of the pattern 000 so we
have three sites three mutations and 000
means of course that none of these three
mutations has occurred so when you're
starting at the root vertex here and
since none of these mutation has
occurred the first one has not occurred
and the probability for that to happen
is 1 minus theta 1 the second one has
also not occurred so the probability is
1 minus theta2 and you can stop here
because if that mutation has not
occurred number 3 cannot occur by
definition of the model right if you
don't have mutation to there's no way to
acquire mutation free you can write here
x 1 if you want to get that one from the
deterministic line of of the matrix on
the previous slide and so on not in
particular that some mutation patterns
now have probability 0 such as this one
for example 001 so only mutation 3 so
this particular model does not allow the
genotype that has only mutation 3
because again you would need mutation to
first so there's no way for that
mutation for that genotype to occur in
this particular model
so what you're doing is you have no way
of computing the probabilities for each
genotype the model itself gives you the
dependency the directed dependencies of
the mutations and in a way you're also
excluding some of the genotypes to
happen from this evolutionary process
yes please such a model if you assume
that there are no errors in the sense
that if they're you know part mutation
then take care that their daughter
therefore you can simply you know take
your samples and be like I shall hold
your own day and you reconstruct the
tree you don't need the probe listing
model so what do you get out of it
that's what we're doing essentially but
we will of course later move on to the
situation where there is noise and so on
but but it that's the basic idea for
let's say the error free setting later
we will move on to look at observation
errors and as I said later we will also
have a notion of the dynamics of the
waiting times and so on but that's
that's absolutely true and we will do
that in a moment ok so this model was
originally proposed and described by by
Rick desper and Alejandro sheffer and
and others and and when they came up
with it they presented a computationally
efficient and also statistically
consistent estimator for the tree
structure and the way it worked is is
very nice so you start with a complete
weighted graph and you have to use these
particular weights that depend only on
pairwise probabilities among events and
if you construct within this complete
graph the maximum weight branching then
it turns out that you will give me
enough data and so on you will recover
the two three if the data comes from
such a tree model so in a way there is a
nice solution and at this point we are
not requiring by the way that the data
is perfect in any way we will make that
assumption later again
I completely agree with you but this
particular algorithm that has been
proposed originally does not require
data to be perfect and in fact they give
some balance depending on the
observation area and so on how good how
good it is and you know it's not
terribly good but it's used in practice
and again it's computationally efficient
okay now these trees can also be
interpreted as a process in time we will
do that more carefully later on but I
want to give the intuition right away so
if you just assume a Poisson process
exponential waiting times for each
mutation so TI is the waiting time for
mutation I to occur and it follows an
exponential distribution with rate
lambda I and in addition the observation
time or the sampling time the 10th the
time you look at your sample follows
another exponential distribution with
rate lambda s here then you can simply
set these probabilities from the
aquagenic three more feet i as lambda i
divided by lambda i plus lambda a span
and that just means that the mutation
will occur before you look at the sample
so these are two competing Exponential's
and you only see the mutation if it
occurs before your sample before you
take the sample right so you so you need
to look late enough basically in order
to be able to see the mutation that's
that's always saying here but that idea
will reoccur later on so I want to make
that point early on and okay here's just
another example of a root vertex and now
you would have a notion of waiting times
or waiting time distributions maybe
average waiting times along each of
these edges so let me now move on to a
model that we call a conjunctive asian
network and the motivation is basically
now to generalize from the tree model to
a more general directed acyclic graph
and all we're getting very very close to
what you were saying so we relax the
tree assumption and now we consider a
partial
order of these genetic events and by
this symbol here we denote this this set
this partially ordered set or pull set
for short and and we want to define what
an order ideal here is so an order ideal
G so this is the same notation as for
the genotypes it's just a subset of a
subset of genetic events that is closed
downward with respect to the post set
and that simply means that if you have
two events that are partially ordered
that are ordered that where you have a
relation between them you once more than
e2 in the pole set and the larger one is
in G then it implies that the smaller
one must already be in G so everything
smaller with respect to the pole set
must also be inside that set then we
call that set in water idea and then
it's not hard to see and I'll show it to
you in the example I think it becomes
very obvious these order ideals are
exactly the genotypes that are
compatible with the order constraints in
E and by compatible I mean they don't
have probability 0 remember already
ended in the tree some of the genotypes
have probability 0 and I'm saying the
ones that are not constant do not have
constant probability 0 our executive
order ideals of this fall set so also in
this model we continue to assume what's
usually monotonicity so each event can
occur only if all predecessors have
occurred remember in the tree of course
tree is defined by the fact that you
have exactly one or let's say at most
one except for the route you have
exactly one predecessor and require that
predecessor to occur before we can move
on with the next mutation now we have a
more general directed acyclic graph and
the way we extend it here there's other
ways but the way we extended here is
that we require all of the predecessors
to occur before we can move on to the
next mutation and that's where the term
conjunctive asia network comes from you
need all in like an end between all your
predecessors before you can move on to
the next mutation
so here's an example so here's such a
post set among for genetic events simply
labeled 1 2 3 4 and the relations are
listed down here but they're also
indicated in the graph here the has a
diagram so one is more than 32 is small
and 31 is more than four and two is more
than four these are the only relations
among the mutations that are present
here now the order ideals in fact they
they form a lattice but it doesn't
really matter so much right or you can
also look this just as a set the order
ideas are all these subsets here
starting with the empty set that's clear
let's look maybe at one of them to check
that property maybe one to four so what
I'm claiming is that in this set any
event that's smaller than any of these
is already inside so for example let's
look at event one where there's nothing
smaller than one so that's fine let's
look at two there's nothing smaller than
two that's that's also fine so only four
is interesting but smaller than four is
one and two but one and two are already
in the set so this set is closed
downward with respect to the partial
order okay that's these are the older
ideas and as I said these are exactly
the genotypes on the right hand side of
course that's the same object i'm just
writing these subsets and just
indicating them now as binary strings so
that's probably more intuitive for
genotype but throughout this this
lecture I will use either the subset
notation for genotype or this binary
binary string so we call that the
genotype lettuce here so in a way these
partial order see among the mutations
imply a certain subset of genotypes
where the mutation the evolutionary
process is happening and is occurring
so I also want to mention this notion of
an exit set without going through the
formulas is not very complicated but i
think the intuition is enough here so
the exit set of a certain genotype is
simply the set of mutations that can
occur next or that could occur next so
for example suppose you have this
genotype here that's defined by mutation
one and two then you have to look at
your post set in order to see which
mutations are possible now and it turns
out if you have one and two you can have
next either three or four so you can go
either this way acquiring free in
addition or even you can go this way
acquiring mutation number four in
addition so the exit set of this
genotype would consist of three and four
and we simply write them that the exit
set of G is the set of three and four
the exit said let's say of this genotype
will just consist of two and so on so
exit set means you're sitting somewhere
in the lettuce what are my options
basically to acquire additional
mutations ok with that notation we can
write down what the conjunctive asia
network is as a statistical model again
it has parameters theta one opposite
ends one parameter for each each genetic
event in my pulse at E and I'm writing
down what the probability is of
observing a certain genotype G well for
each genetic event that has occurred in
this genotype i have to multiply the
probability of that genetic event theta
e i get a factor theta ii and for each
event that could have occurred but has
not occurred namely for each event in
the exit set of g i get a factor of 1
minus theta because it has not occurred
1 minus theta is the probability that
the mutation has not occurred so that's
maybe in a way the simplest way to write
down the model and i think it's very
intuitive you have a certain number of
mutations and you say ok the probability
for that is the probability of each
mutation in the genotype multiply them
and
n times 1 minus the probability of each
event that could have happened according
to the constraints of my model but has
not happened I think it's very very
intuitive equivalently we can again take
the perspective of a Beijing network
because at the end of the day these are
specific the asian network so for many
of you will be familiar with Beijing
network so I want to make that
connection here you can say that again
it's the Beijing network for these
random variable x e indexed by the pole
set and there is an edge again whenever
there is a cover relation in my pole set
and the local probability distributions
now are again highly specialized
remembered so these local probability
distributions the number of rows know is
two to the number of parents right
because now I have to say what's the
probability of the mutation given any
constellation of the parents I have
let's say n parents n is not good
because in an order M parents right then
2 to the M is the number of
constellations the parent vertices can
have so this matrix has two to the
number of parents rows and 2 columns and
for each constellation of the parents I
have to say what what's the probability
for the mutation to happen and most of
the time that probability is 0 because I
allow progression only in the last row
and I didn't put the the label here of
the road the last row is of course the
one where all the parents nodes are
equal to 1 so we're all the parent
mutations have occurred only then I can
move on to the next mutation and that
probability is again simply theta II and
again I have only one free parameter per
vertex unlike in a general bheja network
with them of parameters would grow much
faster obviously so you can think of
this model as a very specialized and in
that sense also very simple Beijing
network model okay here's a here's the
the continuation of this example that's
the same pole set I've been showing you
before and again the lattice of
genotypes of order ideals and I'm just
writing down here the nonzero
all probabilities several genotypes of
course again have probability zero here
the nonzero ones are listed here let's
look at one of them for example this one
that's the probability of the pattern 1
to 12 is this genotype so probability
for this one is Theta once at times
theta 2 and then 1 minus theta 3 not
developing this mutation and 1 minus
theta for not developing this mutation
that's as simple as it is okay so i will
not go into great detail here but these
cbn models are very nice and simple so
if you want to do maximum likelihood
estimation of the parameters you can
directly write down what the estimator
is also model selection is very easy and
without noise you have essentially
already told us how it works you just
have to check for each relation just go
through all possible relations and you
check whether there is a contradiction
in your data set and if there is no
contradiction you throw that relation in
right and in that the post set that you
get in this manner turns out to be the
maximum likely posted under this very
simple model so that is of course
computationally efficient and
straightforward we also looked at the
algebraic properties of these models and
they also turn out to be very simple in
a way in and very nice so if you analyze
the model as a algebraic statistical
model you can easily write down the
equations that define this more okay so
next I want to move on to what we call
the continuous-time conjunctive patient
work network so staying with the same
structure but now giving it a notion of
a waiting time and I'm not doing this
quite as formal but but i think it's
it's clear how it works so here's the
basic idea again so we're starting again
with a partial order among genetic
events here's an example of these for
genetic events ABC and D and and again
the way to think of this model is that
each individual tumor that we observe
is an independent realization of this
process so for example here in tumor one
we had one clonal expansion that led to
the fixation of mutation beam and at
this point we have looked at the tumor
so that would mean we would observe
mutation be in this tumor in the second
tumor we had a clonal expansion driven
by mutation a a second one driven by be
a third one driven by C and then we have
sampled then we have taken a biopsy may
be of the two blind we have looked at
the tumor and the third one has for
example first a then B then d so
remember that the linear order in each
of these tumors here is is different but
all of these linear orders are
compatible with the partial order so in
a way the partial order is a summary of
what's common among these individual
tumors so the data we would obtain from
this is what i already said as a binary
matrix here are my tumors here my
genetic events ABCD for the first one
would be 0 1 0 0 because own invitation
be and the second one would be 1110 and
so on now in reality these observations
will not be perfect and we will have
noise on top of that so it might be that
this mutation we were just not also it
might be that here for example we call
the false positive or here for example
we were not able to detect the mutation
and we get a zero in our data and
despite the fact there should be one
idly so that's more reasonable to assume
such an additional process of of noisy
observations here so now we will
explicitly model waiting times and we
will again use exponential distributions
and that's the simplest thing to do
clearly so the way it works in this
example is as follows so for mutation a
we simply have an exponential waiting
time by a specific parameter lambda a
for mutation be we have another
exponential waiting time with rate
lambda B and now for mutation see will
for C to happen you first have to wait
for a 20
and then you can move on to see there
for the waiting time for mutation see is
the waiting time for mutation a plus an
individual contribution for the
particular mutation see so you first in
order to get this one you first wait for
that one and then you move on waiting
for mutation see and permutation d and
both a and B have to occur both have
have to occur before so the waiting time
for mutation d is now the maximum of a
and B because after waiting the maximum
time both of them will have occurred
plus the contribution for mutation d
okay and in addition there's the
observation time here now the
observation time we don't know and
therefore it's another random variable
and we just assume another exponential
distribution here mainly because we
don't know better what that what that
distribution should be so why don't we
know the sampling time we know when we
have taken the sample from the patient
right we know when we did it we also
know how old the patient is and so on
but what we don't know is when this
evolutionary process started so we don't
know that the time point relative to the
onset of the evolutionary process
because in general we have no idea when
the first genetic event occurred in the
tumor therefore this the sampling time
is not known again nor who is you the
four samples of the same yes I assume
exactly that this distribution is is
over all samples that's the simplest one
can do well it's okay but but still you
take on a random sample out of before
every sample that hearing today right so
every sample started in a different
location yes oh yeah yeah exactly the
parameters shared across samples and in
each I mean it's here right the this
it's indicated in the figure it's
different now
absolutely okay hmm so yeah I think this
is a bit repetitive fear no TI is again
the waiting time for a mutation I as we
have seen and the continuous-time CBN
model is now defined in the way we have
essentially already seen on the previous
slide that's just written down slightly
different but again you're drawing
individual exponential waiting times for
each mutation and to implement this
order constraint that's hard order
constrained by requiring the maximum
waiting time for all the predecessors
plus the individual contribution okay
can we learn this model and the answer
is in an ideal world again yes it's in
fact easy so for fully observed data
parameter maximum likelihood estimation
and also model selection are again easy
and they're almost the same as for the
CBN model but what means fully observed
data so fully observed data means that
for each mutation we observe when it has
occurred we observe the time point of
occurrence and that's of course
something we will never have in reality
in reality we only look at the outcome
of this process at some point in time
but we never observe for each mutation
in each patient when exactly hazard
occurred so we don't have that data and
so that's the situation that's called
censoring in in statistics and and
that's why we introduce the sampling
time TS which follows as I set another
exponential distribution so there's
different ways not to deal with this one
way is to use an e/m algorithm so to
estimate these these observation times
so the observation time but also the
occurrence times of the mutations in an
iterative fashion and I just want to
give you one key ingredient here so the
East step is usually the most difficult
that that's also the case here now in
this estep essentially you have to
compute the expectation of a maximum of
waiting times now that's in general a
bit difficult to compute an into
an expectation over a maximum of random
variables and this is the solution that
you can derive it has a structure that
looks like this basically in order to
compute the maximum over let's say these
three waiting times t1 t2 t3 you have to
sum over all possible pathways in the
hypercube starting from the empty set
here going to the set that has all of
the mutation so you need to consider all
of these pathways and then the
contribution you get from each pathway
is the probability of picking that
pathway which is given just buy a
product of these competing Exponential's
at each point you have several choices
and you just need to multiply the
probability that you pick that one times
the expected waiting time that pathway
it takes so there's a very intuitive
notion basically in order to compute how
long does it take to get here maximum of
these well you have to consider again
all pathways and for each pathway you
have to weigh the password by its
probability and then look at its
expected waiting time okay so the point
I really want to emphasize is that these
post sets now in a way define the
geometry of the genotype space and here
are a few examples again only on three
mutations if you have a linear order if
your if your partial order happens to be
a total order then from this hypercube
of combinatorial possible combinations
of mutations you're really cutting out a
single pathway if you have a linear
order of mutations it of course implies
that the genotypes are only those right
that your mutation process can take on
on the other side if your posted is
empty no other constraints among the
mutations then you have the full
hypercube then any mutational pathway is
possible so in a way the idea of the
model is to say look this is too strict
that's the vogelstein model right this
is too strict the data doesn't fit it
and this would mean all mutations are
independent right there's no relations
among the mutation so the idea is to say
maybe there's something in between it is
reasonable to find some order
strains among the mutations we cannot
expect a total order but there might be
some relations that are shared across
different tumors and those we want to
capture in this partial order and
effectively we're cutting out a subspace
of this hypercube so summer we are
saying look the evolutionary process
essentially happens on a much smaller
subset rather than the entire hypercube
I mean this hypercube pictures a bit
misleading anyways especially when it
comes to larger amounts of mutations
here right because an all natural
population for reasonable numbers of n 2
to the N is easily much larger than any
population size so in reality
populations always live on a much
smaller subspace and you can also see
this as an attempt to identify the
subspace of the complete hypercube where
the evolutionary process it really takes
place okay I briefly want to talk about
noise and this one is called the hidden
conjunctive patient network and yes this
models you are ignoring the fact that
maybe you are observing multiple times
certain subset which ones which can also
be informative so for example maybe
the ones just move in something's the
same journey well the observations are
all regarded as independent observations
and if you have the count that you have
for each binary vector but it enters I
mean okay I didn't write down the
likelihood but the likelihood is of
course where's at least the probability
somewhere this is it does matter this is
a property for one observation the
likelihood would of course just be the
product over these guys for all
observations and if there's a certain
observation that occurs five times that
factor occurs five times so it will
enter the likelihood absolutely it on
the end so are their measures to
regularize this process and make sure
you're not overfitting essential
interests enumerate in all possible
paths so no we're not regular rising
here in any way I think the probably the
main answer here is that the number of
parameters is not very large the number
of parameters is just the number of
vertices in the graph so it's not the
usual Beijing network learning situation
is okay the number of vertices is fixed
but the more edges you put into your
graph the more parameters you get and
that's not the case with this very
specific model because the number of
parameters is always equal to the number
of nodes so in that sense you cannot
overfit I'm not saying in general you
cannot over fit but in the usual way by
just adding more parameters by adding
more edges you cannot over fit
okay so let me talk a bit more about the
noise maybe quickly so this is again the
representation of our settings so far
but let's this is now represented as a
full probabilistic graphical model again
we in this example we have for genetic
events these are the waiting times t1 22
23 24 and these are the relationships
this is the partial order among the
waiting times here is our observation
time or time to diagnosis and the
censoring event here that finally gives
rise to the observed law let's say to
the genotypes x 1 up to x 4 is what we
have looked at already now in addition i
want to add this noisy observation level
so now we assume that what we're
observing is this genotype y so binary
random variate y 1 up to y 4 and they
are again obtained from x the true
genotype we think of X now as the true
genotype why is the observed genotype
they obtained from X by a simpler arrow
process an arrow model that gives the
rate of flipping a bit okay so that of
course just simply adds more hidden data
to this problem and so on this model
only the grain oats down here are
observed and all of this is hidden data
and what we're mainly interested in is
the edges among those nodes here right
but in a way we need all of this we need
this for the censoring process and we
need this if we want to account for
noisy observations explicitly so one way
to do this now is it is again to use any
em algorithm and you can use for example
in STM that accounts for these two types
of hidden data again the time points of
mutations and sampling and the true
genotype as as opposed to the observed
genotype model selection now becomes
more complicated you can sample we did
some simulated annealing you can do
other things of course then we also
a bayesian approach of of this model and
in fact this work that thomas has done
who's who is here fellow on the program
he developed a markov chain monte carlo
sampler to sample from the posterior
distribution and he introduced some new
move types in order to make this sampler
more efficient still turns out to be a
hard problem for large number of events
but it did make some progress here so
this slide just shows that it really
works in these cases and that you really
get most likely really get a sample from
the posterior distribution and of course
then you can quantify or the
uncertainties that you have in your
estimated posted structure for example
and this is boiled down here to pairwise
relations either among the cover
relations or among all relations and
then you see some of them are fairly
stable have a very high posterior
probability and of course others are not
that stable ok I want to go through a
few examples and applications and
historically these models have been
applied to CGH data and they have become
a bit out of fashion but nevertheless I
want to mention it here so comparative
genome have relation is a technique to
detect large-scale events in these
cancer genomes namely the the loss of
the gain of a large part of a chromosome
arm so here's an example where these
data was available for renal cell
carcinoma 251 cases and we just looked
at the twelfth most frequent of these
events and they're all labeled in this
manner for example- 3p so the minus
stands for a loss three is the
chromosome number and p is the small arm
of chromosome 3 so that would be a loss
of the small arm of chromosome 3 and if
it's a plus for example here that will
be again on chromosome 17 and Q for
example would be the larger arm of
chromosome 17 so for example then this
is the in a way an optimal pole set that
we estimated here and for example you
might be interested in early thence loss
of
well of course on three is reassuring
because the phone Apple lindo gene sits
on this chromosome and that's a
well-known tumor suppressor gene for
renal cell carcinoma but the model
indicates that there's another early
event here namely loss of a larger of
course on for so it gives you an
indication for starting to look for
early events that drive the initiation
of this cancer so here's a link to
survival analysis this is again a
picture of our complete model now and in
a way a lot of people used a genetic
data to predict survival of cancer
patients now if you believe this model
you would say okay this is the observed
data but this is an hour model the true
genotype so in a way the true genotype
here should be more informative about
survival then the noisy one that we
estimate right so what we did is we
simply compare models predicting
survival based on the observed genotype
versus the estimated true genotype y we
don't know that yugioh type what the
model gives us a way of estimating this
and it turns out that indeed the
survival predictions become become
significantly better if you move to the
estimated genotype here so the way yes
assuming this example that you can
actually improve things if you also
consider you know what type of mutations
each genotype have right because you
already reconstructed the tree so maybe
you know if you have a certain mutation
it's more as more impacted that in
another mutation somehow no no it's this
is a multivariate whatever Cox
proportional model so you still have a
weight for each mutation and so ever
they would assume
actually converted of the tree and not
only of the downstream effects then
maybe you could even do better you can
derive other things from the tree and I
will do on the next slide you are too
fast you're always on the next slide I
will do so on the next slide here the
point is you can use the model in a way
to denoise the data right and the idea
is this model is shared across all tumor
samples so in a way using your you
borrow strength from the other samples
you say okay it tends to look like this
therefore I have a chance to somehow
correct the genotype and and then the
deed that gives a better prediction of
survival so now we're doing again what
would that has suggested namely one way
to use the structure of the tree is
something that we tend to call a genetic
progression score but it really just is
an expected waiting time namely the
expected waiting time for all the
mutations that I find in my tumor or
more precisely that I think are present
in my tumor maybe the XJ rather than the
YJ so I'm just saying okay I think these
mutations should be present in the tumor
what's the average time it takes for
these to accumulate and that's a measure
of how far the tumor has progressed
because the longer it takes on average
for these to occur the longer the tumor
has progressed and in a range of
different cancer we evaluated this as a
prognostic marker in each case comparing
to the standard markers also simple
things like just the sum of mutations
and so on and in most cases it gave a
better separation or by the prediction
of survival and here you are explicitly
using the structure of the of the post
set in order to compute this quantity
absolutely I maybe skip this one here
and use my last five minutes to talk
about pathway level progression so the
idea is now that well there's so much
variation among the order in which
mutations occur
maybe this is because what really
matters is the pathways that are
affected maybe it looks very diverse on
the gene level but maybe it's much
better on the pathway level so the first
and maybe simplest thing you can do is
you take your observed genotypes your
binary matrix here and you simply map it
onto a given set of pathways and you're
saying that the pathway is mutated
whenever at least one of the genes in
the pathway is mutated so you take your
favorite list of pathways and then what
you get is again a binary matrix the
roles are again the tumors but the
columns are no pathways you cannot read
it here but this is you know anger
genesis apoptosis and so on whatever
your favorite list of pathways is and
then you can use the same model and
estimate dependencies among also
pathways so for example here's an
example from Leo blastoma on the
left-hand side is the pole set on the
level of trees on the right hand side is
the pole set on the level of pathways
and apoptosis for example is the single
early event here that makes a lot of
sense then come a lot of signaling
pathways there's some dependencies here
invasion is a very late event if we
compare the stability of the two models
in a statistical sense turns out the
model is much more stable on the pathway
level so giving some indication that
maybe the pathway level is the more
relevant level to describe tumor
progression and we did this for a range
of other tumors let me skip this one and
then we also pooled data from different
tumors and that's what I call you a
global model of pathway progression
simply meaning that this is data across
different tumor types and you get a
fairly stable model actually where again
apoptosis is of course in the early
event several signal pathways are
involved and so on so there's certainly
things that are shared among different
tumors tumor types yes
yeah by stability I mean here how sure
am I about the edges in my in my tree
and depending on what your inference is
in let's say in the likelihood framework
you would maybe typically do a bootstrap
analysis to assess that if you do
Beijing analysis you can look at
posteriors and so on okay and then this
idea came up already some time ago
actually I think when when Ben and I
were at some conference at some point
that idly would like to do the two
things at the same time estimating the
structure of the pathways de novo and
learning their dependencies and and then
Ben and Fabio finally did this realize
this in a paper published last year
where the idea is to identify groups of
genes pathways by the mutual exclusivity
criterion and then they restricted their
model to linear pathways so their model
can find these groups of genes de
Neuville so I'm not starting with a
given list of pathways and instead I
find these groups and I can order them
in an optimal linear fashion so so they
approach this problem from a
combinatorial point of view and it turns
out on the reasonable assumption that
it's an np-hard problem even if you
restrict to the linear order which which
might be simpler than allowing for other
orders all right the where so each box
here is a pathways a group of genes
rights for example here you have a PC
and whatever FBX still is in here these
are sources of previously no no I mean
you mean if you check later yes but the
message didn't know about it so based on
this yourself I mean the idea is that
within each group these jeans are
mutually exclusive they show a pattern
of mutual exclusivity and that that has
oh yes I mean that's the idea that that
I mean the model wants to suggest that
these probably operate together and for
the progression you need to affect this
pathway this group of genes that it can
be either one and it typically is only
one of them correct me for you if I'm
worth of you if I'm wrong okay and and
the same idea we looked at from a
probabilistic point of view so here's
again here again our waiting times t1 t2
and so on and now we have random
variables you and these are now the
waiting times for the pathways right so
in order for a pathway to be mutated you
need at least one of the mutations to
occur first and for the next mutations
to occur you have to wait until the
upstream pathways are mutated so the
model becomes a little bit more involved
not because there's no waiting times for
genes and waiting times for pathways
there's again an observation time and
there's again a layer here of noisy
observations and this model now combines
the waiting time based way of finding
which two exclusivity sets that been
mentioned yesterday and the CBN model
the waiting time CBN more that I talked
about today and here's just one example
from this model and it looks very
similar it's a bit more explicit here
because of these groups you can now see
these patterns of course imperfect
patterns of neutral exclusivity is an
example from Leo blastoma so we would
identify this group here and then you
see a nice pattern of mutual exclusivity
and these are the dependencies among the
groups okay with that I would like to
stop here and I'm happy to take
questions thank
yeah so what you talked about yesterday
near explained us before was essentially
sort of looking at the matrix from two
different angles have people not right
or so the data available that if you had
multiple biopsies with different
mixtures of clones clonal populations to
combine that with these models that you
talked about this morning yeah that's
that's a very good point so most of this
has been developed in the times where we
had one sample per tumor right and and
again the idea was to learn something
that's common among a group of tumors
now a lot of data is accumulating from
within 12 mar and and it's indeed a very
good question how to use that to also
inform these models I think this is
something hasn't really been done yet
but I know many people are thinking
about it and I mean the simplest thing
we discussed it already yesterday
evening a bit as simplest thing is to
take multiple samples from on tumor as
independent observations in this model
right and maybe give them a gift give
them some weight to account for the fact
that they come from the same individual
to normalize for that but that's clearly
the most straightforward way to do it
I'm sure one can be more clever about it
and so on but that would already make
sense to me because then you're asking
for common features of the evolutionary
process within several tumors